ترقد الحاجه سهام على فراش الاستشفاء منذ
اكتشاف اصابتها بالسرطان قبل نحو عام
وتتلقى علاجها في المركز الوحيد في قطاع
غزه لعلاج السرطان لكن قله الامكانات
المتاحه اخرت اكتشاف اصابتها بالمرض وبدء
علاجها اول شعوب واجهتنا صعوبه اللي هي
التحاليل سواء ارسالها للخارج طبعا لعدم
وجود اجهزه خاصه بالتحاليل هذه وانتظار
النتائج هذه اخذت فتره طويله برضو من
المشاكل اللي واجهتنا اللي هي قصه التصوير
السيتي
فنضطرنا ننتظر فتره طويله ما كانش فيه الا
جهاز واحد في كل قطاع غزه للمرضى السرطان
في اروقه هذا المستشفى ينتظر المرضى
ومرافقوهم طويلا لاجراء فحوص مخبريه او
صور اشعه
فالمتوفر من الاجهزه محدود او معطل في هذا
المركز الذي بدا عمله منذ اكثر من عام
لكنه يعاني كباقي القطاع الصحي من تبعات
الحصار الاسرائيلي الذي اعاق توفير
المعدات والاجهزه الضروريه
جهاز واحد شغال بتموت لعدم وصولها الى
المستشفيات في الدخل وعدم توفر الاجهزه
اللي هي بتنفع لمعالجه الناس هذه اذا
تكلمنا عما ينقص قطاع غزه حقيقه للعلاج هو
العلاج الاشعاعي ثم العلاج
بالنظائر المشعه سواء علاجا او تشخيصا
وهذه الاجهزه غير موجوده على الاطلاق في
غزه على الاقل ثلث مرضايا يحتاجون الى هذا
العلاج سيا اسرائيل باستمرار اعاقه ادخال
المعدات الطبيه وقطع غيارها الى قطاع غزه
تترك تداعياتها على القطاع الصحي والمرضى
الذين يحرم كثيرون منهم من السفر للعلاج
في الخارج فالسفر من غزه الى الضفه
الغربيه او الداخل المحتل يحتاج الى
اجراءات وتصاريح تصدرها سلطات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي والحصول عليها غير مضمون غالبا
او غير متاح لكثيرين حتى لو كانت الغايه
من السفر للعلاج من امراض لا يتوفر علاجها
في قطاع غزه المجتمع الدولي مطالب بالضغط
على اسرائيل من اجل اجبارها على الالتزام
بما تمليه عليها اتفاقيه جنيف الرابعه
والسماح بدخول المواد الاساسيه الى قطاع
غزه وايضا السماح بسفر المرضى المحولين
للعيش بالخارج
واقع ترتب عليه تدهور متواصل للق طاع
الصحي في غزه مع استمرار الحصار
الاسرائيلي الذي يحول دون وصول المتطلبات
الاساسيه للقطاع هبه كيلا الجزيره من
مدينه غزه